hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
novel roles of actin cytoskeleton on
mitochondrial dynamics and homeostasis
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored
by andor for more information on our
sponsor please visit
andor.com i would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
today's presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits
at the conclusion of this webinar please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce our
presenters dr raj chakrabarti
research associate at geisel school of
medicine at dartmouth
dr claudia florindo product specialist
life sciences and or technology
and also joining us we have meredith
price product and business manager at
amaris
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr chakravarti dr florindo meredith you
may now begin your presentations
hello everyone um i'm raj and thank you
christine for
for the wonderful introduction and
thanks to uh claudia
for giving me the opportunity to present
my work that i've been doing
um in the higgs lab so what you can see
in this screen today i'm going to talk
about
is the role of actin filaments which is
one of the cytoskeletal proteins
in the cells and the role it has on the
mitochondrial dynamics
now from the from the from the image
that you can see over here
is actin filaments are everywhere so
whatever you see in green
are actin filaments but specifically i'm
going to talk about
um the actin filaments that i'm labeling
over here
which is in the peri-nuclear region and
that dynamically comes up
and then goes down again so dynamically
action filaments assemble
and they depolymerize and this
polymerization and the polymerization of
the actin filaments in this very nuclear
region what you can see here
affects mitochondrial dynamics and
mitochondrial division in a unique way
um and i i should say that this this
image that you can see over here is one
of the first images i took on the
android scope when it was demoing in our
lab
and this still is our best image that we
got and we published this
a couple of years back so i'll start
with uh
introducing the first two main players
in today's talk actin and mitochondria
actin as i told you is the cytoskeleton
protein
so in cells actin exists in monomers
and in filamentous form and it can
spontaneously
assemble into filaments but this is
kinetically
unfavorable so the monomers can assemble
into filaments and it has to go through
this step called nucleation where
three actin monomers form a nucleus and
this is
unfavorable because of the high
dissociation constant
of this nucleus back into monomers
so cells have devised the various ways
in order to stabilize this
uh nucleation step and also help in the
elongation step
uh thereby forming filaments and two
very important proteins
that are required for this process
are a group of protein called formants
so what forming
does is it can stabilize this nucleation
step as you can see over here
and additionally it can stay add this
bars
in and thereby help adding monomers and
extending these filaments it also helps
in the elongation of the filament
a somewhat different approach is taken
by another group of proteins called the
rp3 complex
this is a complex about 617 proteins
um that can get on the
existing mother filament on the sides of
the existing mother filament
and then it can extend these filaments
as a typical
70 degree angle and unlike the formants
what you can see here is it needs an
existing mother filament
for its actin assembly
so what i'm going to talk about today is
a typical role of a typical
form in protein that we found out in
mitochondrial dynamics and for the time
sake
i won't be explaining the role of of
three complex in mitochondrial dynamics
which by the way has a very different
role
in the mitochondrial dynamics now the
second layer is mitochondria
this is a very uh textbook image of a
mitochondria that you will recall in
your
biochem classes mitochondria
is also pictured as these kidney-shaped
organelles
it has two elaborate membranes um the
outer mitochondrial membrane which is
black and the inner membrane which is
thrown into poles
of cristae and this force of crispy
harbored
the electron transport chain complexes
that help in the generation of atp
but if you look at the cells it doesn't
look like these
fill shaped singular organelles contrary
to
what i showed you in in that image when
you stain mitochondria
in cells it comes in different shapes
and sizes
some of the mitochondria in the cells
are elongated and in network
sometimes they are fragmented and even
in
lower organisms like yeast it has its
definite shape and size
so how does mitochondria uh modulate its
shape and size
the inherent ability of mitochondria to
divide
and fuse generates all these different
shapes and sizes of mitochondria
so what you can see here in the screen
is to your left
is a elongated branched mitochondria
and towards its right is small
mitochondria
and this elongated mitochondria can
divide and generate these smaller
mitochondria
contrary to this the smaller
mitochondria can also
fuse back and generate the elongated
mitochondria and the cycles of division
and fusion is very well coordinated in
the sense now i should tell you that
mitochondria is a unique organelle which
cannot be
generated the novo it has to be
generated from a pre-existing
mitochondria so the
cycles of division and fusion is very
important for mitochondrial maintenance
these divisions and fusion of
mitochondria
is is enacted upon by its own repertoire
of produce
one of the important proteins for
mitochondrial division
is drp1 so what is dfp1 so here if you
want
is a dynamine family gtps protein that
is
in the cytosol and we found out that a
population of it also exists on the er
but during mitochondrial division it can
get on to
the site where the mitochondria needs to
divide
and then help in the mitochondrial
division
of the important proteins of fusion is
called opa-1 which i won't be going into
details for today's talk
but just remember that this protein is
also important for the inner membrane
fusion of the mitochondria
now why do the cell needs to divide and
and and
fuse mitochondria what is it is it all
needed
um the short answer is yes it's needed
for the normal physiology of the cell
on one hand fusion of mitochondria helps
in the complementation of the
mitochondrial dna
and this is very well required
for the maintenance of mitochondrial
function
what fusion also does is it dissipates
the metabolic energy
now for its proper functioning
mitochondria has a definite membrane
potential
and by fusing two mitochondria a part of
the mitochondria can regain the
metabolic energy that it needs
if it's damaged so what are the utilize
of the fission process or the division
process
now a very important uh a function of
mitochondrial division
is in mitotiy where a a deranged
mitochondria is turned over
by specific autopsy known as mitoxin and
for the autophagosomes to form around
this mitochondria it needs to be broken
down into smaller particles
and that's why you need the mitochondria
to divide and get rid of those particles
another important function of the
mitochondrial division is distribution
of the
mitochondria now this is specially
relevant in the neurons
where in the in the longer parts of the
axons and the dendrites
the elongated or the elaborately
branched mitochondria cannot get there
so you need the mitochondrial decision
in in the cell body of a neuron
for it to be facilitated uh distribution
along the axon and to the terminal parts
of the axon
what people have also shown is uh this
division of mitochondria
is is required for the cytophone c
release and apoptosis
and for us the most important of the
mitochondrial division function
is in the growth and inheritance where
there is a stimulated mitochondrial
division just before the cell division
where these divided mitochondria have to
be distributed into two daughter cells
so that each of the daughter cells
have equal number of mitochondria and
this is very important
so i start with a very basic model of
the mitochondrial division
so what would it have as i told you it
will have this particular protein called
dip one which is a dynamic family gtpas
that's in the cytosol
and it will obviously have mitochondria
so division starts with a division
signal and by the end of the talk i'll
let you know what this division signal
actually means but the division signal
as of now is is the site where the
mitochondria needs to divide or where
the c1 will finally assemble
to divide the mitochondrial outer
membrane
so once this pre-existing site is
designated
trp1 comes along and starts
oligomerizing at these sites
and upon gtp hydrolysis this
squeezes the outer mitochondrial
membrane and finally helps in the
mitochondrial division now this is a
very simple
a way of of explaining how mitochondria
defines
and as my talk goes i will add
levels of complexity to this apparently
very basic model of mitochondrial
division
so our interest in the mitochondrial
division and actin
uh uh dates back to this study from the
lab
where as i told you one of the foreman
proteins called inf2 which let me remind
you
is a protein that can help assemble
actin filaments
by stabilizing the nucleation tip and
also by helping
the elongation step and when we knock
down a particular form then call inf2
what we see is this elongated structure
of the mitochondria as you can see over
here compared to the control cells and
this was intriguing to us
especially because this formula is not
on mitochondria
so where is this formula located this
formula has two different isoforms
and these are the domain architecture of
a specific formant
and i won't be going into the details of
the domains but just uh uh
to be simple enough on the fh1 and fh2
domains which are pretty well conserved
in all the i
uh performance is used
for um the action assembly purpose and
this did and the dad region
is used for its auto inhibition now inf2
in the cells exists in two different
isoforms
one of the isoforms which we label as
cat because of the terminal system
and the other isoform which we label as
non-cat does not have some terminal
geominer assets
because of the presence of this system
it gets modified and then it gets lodged
onto the er so what you can see here is
inf2 tax which is completely er bound
and if you express the non-cats in the
cells contrary to what you see over here
it's completely cytosolic so this is
where our
intriguing fact is is that if you
deplete cells of inf2 which is either on
site
or on er you get an elongated
mitochondria
so we were fascinated by this and we
wanted to understand how was inflating
mitochondrial dynamics and let me and
just uh
just uh uh information that inf2 is
mutated in two human diseases
um one is a kidney disease called focal
segmental
glomerulous sclerosis and the other is a
terminal of neuropathy known as
chakramedic two disease
so as i told you inf2 is is localized on
the er membrane and for today's talk
i'll be a specific on the text isoform
and what we can do is i need to
like many other formants is also auto
inhibited
and we need to activate this protein and
a unique way that we can activate this
protein is by
uh raising the intracellular calcium so
once you increase the cytosolic calcium
either by bringing in calcium from the
cellular source
or by allowing er to release with
calcium
ions can get activated and so we use
both these techniques so the first one
we use
is by bringing in calcium from this
cellular source
these are some of the calcium stores in
the cells the cytosol mainly has
about point zero zero one millimolar of
calcium
whereas the er has about point
five millimolar of calcium the resting
uh
mitochondrial calcium is also very
similar to the cytosolic calcium levels
and
the the media that we image the cells in
has
over one millimolar of of calcium so
when you add this drug called ionomycin
it simply binds calcium in the cellular
medium
and because of this huge concentration
gradient of calcium across this membrane
it can bring in calcium into the cytosol
and this raises the cytosolic calcium
and we can image this and find a sharp
spike of cytosolic calcium
which goes down by about 100 to 150
seconds
what we also notice is this influx of
calcium
also induces an e-flux from the er
stores
and we can measure this if we target a
specific uh
er found calcium sensor we can see that
there is a sharp spike
downwards of the er calcium eat flux
compared to the dmsos
so either by releasing it from the er
or by bringing it from the cytosol from
the extracellular source we can activate
infp
and once it's activated the first thing
it does is make this
nucleus of actin and then elongates the
actin filaments on
on the er and we can see this nicely
uh by lifestyle imaging so what you can
see here
is um so just the clarification that all
the movies that i show here
are taken on the android scope um
which helped us a lot and except one of
the movies which is a surprise movie
so this movie is uh in which these are
u2
cells that we have labeled um for actin
filaments in green
over here this is a very nuclear region
which doesn't have a lot of stress
fibers and that's why we
image in this region to uh get a better
hold of the action filaments that come
up um the the red marker is an er marker
with same er and what you will see over
here is once we add
the drug there is this burst of action
filaments which
um overlay with the er marker more or
less
because iof2 is mainly on on the er
so we see this burst of actin filament
that assembles and de-assembles and it's
a it's a very dynamic process and we can
measure this
um in in this graph over here so when we
add iron white in we see a curve of
action
uh filament go up and it goes down by
about 100 to 150 seconds which let me
remind you
is typically the similar time that we
saw of the cytosolic calcium spike so
it's
pretty much in that same ballpark that
the actin filaments form
and disappears
so this uh i told you it is a specific
function of
inf2 um so we tested this out in our
inf2 knockout crisper cell line
in which in the same way we have these
ionic to knockout cells labeled
for actin filaments in green
and when we do a similar treatment like
the previous white dye cells
you don't see any visible actin
filaments that comes up in this very
nuclear
region which suggests that this very
specific function is
this is experience this effect to inf2
and we can add quantify this over here
so the other thing that we noticed um
before i joined the lab is when we treat
the cells with ionomycin on the other
hand we raise intracellular calcium
and activate inf2 we see this grp1
polygonalized on mitochondria and
if you if you label this with the actin
filament curve what you will see
is um the actin filament proceed
curve repeat the dip1 organization
and what the previous postdoc also found
that if you
if you uh inhibited this actin filament
assembly by using a small molecule
inhibitor of the
actin polymerization called lag a so
what ladder a does is it sequesters the
actin monomers
and does not allow the filaments to form
so if you add the drug
simultaneously with your stimulus you
don't have any actin filament assembly
and then the drp1 fails to get onto the
mitochondria
and as i told you that this action
filament assembly is dependent on inf2
and consequently what we also notice is
when you add ionomycin you have a lot of
mitochondria dividing
but if you inhibit this actin filament
assembly either
by using this small molecule in a
mixture called lat a
or by inhibiting this important protein
called gip1
both of these um completely inhibit this
stimulus induced
mitochondrial diffusion so from all
these data um
we we came up with an hypothesis on a
model
in which uh we tried to explain how
ionf2 was
doing its job on mitochondrial division
so mitochondria um
from this wonderful study uh in the
science paper
um is known that mitochondria always
divides at the er intensity
so we'll always have this er where the
mitochondrial division is alkaline
and upon inf2 activation there is burst
of actin filament polymerization on the
er
that helps in the productive trp1
oligomerization
um on the mitochondria because i showed
you from the previous data that if you
don't have this acting filament assembly
the drc organization fails on the
mitochondria
and this dip one under its constrictive
force
is dividing the mitochondrial outer
membrane and thereby
finally helping in the mitochondrial
division
but just from this model what i i
i figured out that there is a gap of
knowledge right over here
and there might be other things
happening between our action filament
assembly and the ip1 organization and
this is where it started to work
on this project what we noticed
is since we are raising the
intracellular calcium
we first found out that there was an
influx of mitochondrial calcium
upon this treatment so this is also one
of the movies that we did um
this is a fast acquisition movie where
we imaged every 100 and
um about 110 milliseconds and we could
see the difference between two
very fast dynamic regions so this is an
e2 os cells
in which we labeled the accent filaments
with green
and the mitochondrial calcium is labeled
in red and once i played a movie what
you are going to see
is the actin filament assembles and
there is a time gap after which the
mitochondrial calcium rise which will be
evident by the increase in fluorescence
of of this red mitochondria
so i play the movie i add anamycin at
this point
the acting filaments come up and then
the mitochondrial calcium arise
so there was a definite time gap between
the actin filament assembly which
happens
right at this point and then the
mitochondrial calcium go
up so this was very intriguing to us now
um we wanted to confirm this um
just because mitochondria is an
excellent calcium buffer so it might
just be that there is a rise in the
intracellular calcium
in the cytosol and then the mitochondria
simply is buffering up this calcium
so but before that we trace out
the events in its sequence and we image
these
um in the fast kinetics mode
and what we saw is these after the
stimulus
after adding inomycin the first thing we
see
is the rise in the cytosolic calcium
levels
which is closely followed by the axon
response
and then which is followed by this
mitochondrial calcium rice so we could
delineate these three even kinetically
though it's very fast and dynamic we
still could delineate it
and we figured out that um the acting
filament assembly
follows the calcium and is dependent on
this calcium rice
and then the mitochondrial calcium goes
up after the accident element descent
now we tested this out in a different
way so what i told you
is we add ionomycin which brings in
um calcium from the extracellular source
and also um in
in in a process it also uh helps in the
er calcium sludge
now we wanted to test this in a more
physiological
uh relevant pathway in which we add an
agonist
that can specifically allow calcium to
flux from the er so nothing comes
in from the extracellular source but
everything comes in
comes out of the er so one of these uh
ligands is called the histamine and you
have
certain groups of receptors called the
histamine receptors so once histamine
binds onto these histamine receptors on
the plasma membrane
it starts a chain of even and generates
a small molecule
called the inositol triphosphate or item
three this ip3
can get on to uh or bind onto ic3
receptors that's specifically on er
and allow er calcium release which
raises the
cytosolic calcium levels so um the
difference from dynamite and treatment
is here we have specified the calcium
source
which is only er and not the
extracellular medium
so we imaged uh solid calcium
actin filaments in green and
mitochondrial calcium in
red in a similar way i showed you uh in
my previous images
these images these are same cells
expressing all these three markers
and we're going to image them in at a
speed of 110 milliseconds of frame
and what you will be easily be able to
see is
there is a rise of calcium
first in the cytosol which is followed
by the actin response and which is
followed by the mitochondrial calcium
uptake
what's also intriguing to see is to this
region here
this is the nucleus of the cell and this
region here is a very nuclear region
which is studied with the er
and you will see that the calcium rice
rises first in this region
and then spreads along in the whole cell
so i'll play the movie i'll add
histamine right over
here and then you can see it rises over
here and then spreads out into the whole
cell
which is followed by the actin response
and green in here and the mitochondrial
catheter so i'll play the movie once
more
we have histamine right over here the
calcium comes up
the actin comes up after that and then
the myofonduel calcium go up so
even when we when we specify the calcium
source we see a similar trend where the
cytosolic calcium goes
up first followed by the actin response
and followed by the mitochondrial
calcium output
so we questioned whether this
mitochondrial calcium uptake is somewhat
dependent on this actin response or is
this a passive
response for the mitochondria to buffer
or mop up
a lot of calcium that's coming out of
this er
and we wanted to do this in a couple of
ways um
first we used this drug called the trend
billionaire which let me remind you
again
uh basically acting monomer
sequestration does
and it's very fast so you can add it um
as you add your histamine or animation
and
um this drug will sequester accent
monomers and will not allow the action
filaments to form
so here is a the curves of the control
cells where you have the actin filaments
labeled here in green and mitochondria
calcium labels here in red
and contrary to what i showed you in my
previous slides where the actin
filaments were preceding the
mitochondrial calcium update
these seem to happen at the same time
just because of the time resolution so
these images were taken every 15 seconds
so you can understand that
both these events are now seemingly at
the same time but if you see the part
and
image faster you can see the difference
between these two even
so we added the this drug um
and we could sequester the actin
filament assembly
or in this blue curve and what we also
saw is these cells in which the actin
filament assembly was hampered the
mitochondrial calcium uptake
was severely hampered so it
seemed that this actin filament assembly
was somehow
helping in the mitochondrial calcium
update
we confirmed this in our ionic to
knockout cells which as i told you does
not have this actin filament assembly
and in these cells
the mitochondrial calcium uptake is
severely reduced
and we can rescue this completely if we
over express
on the inf2 tax which seems to get back
this
acting uh this mitochondria calcium
uptake so from these data it was
apparent to us that
this imf2 mediated actin filament
assembly
was somehow promoting the mitochondrial
calcium oxide
so where was this mitochondria
getting the calcium from i won't go into
the details of the data
but we found out that um the
calcium that gets into the mitochondria
was coming from the er
and not the extracellular resource when
we added itemized
so the question now is how does
actin filament facilitate this er
mitochondrial calcium exchange
now this is a a field which has been
studied for
for a pretty long time now and
it's pretty well documented that the er
docks with mitochondria
at several places and there are bona
fide proteins that can
bridge these er mitochondrial contact
sites which helps
in transfer of not only calcium but also
lipids and
other other substances
so we wondered if actin filaments were
promoting er mitochondria
to facilitate this calcium transfer
so to answer this we did some thin
section en
and um so what you see here is a into a
wildcat cells treated with ionomycin for
about a minute
uh which is supposed to be the peak of
the actin filaments
and the same treatment done in the
knockout cells
and readily what you see is in the wild
type cells the er
disabled over here and the mitochondria
they seem to be tightly bound to each
other
but in the knockout cells these pr
and mitochondria are pretty much far
apart from each other as zoomed in here
so
what you can see is the er is over here
and these are the two mitochondria with
the cristae
and they form these closed contacts
pretty much in the wildlife cells but
this distance here is pretty wide apart
and it believes that distances of 10 to
30 nanometer is required for
efficient transfer of materials from
each mitochondria
and these distances are well over 100
nanometers so
um we quantified this and found out that
bonany treatment in the white side cells
there was
about two-fold increase in the close
contact between er and mitochondria
whereas in the knockout cells you don't
have this increase
because acne filaments were not formed
we wanted to test this in a different
way so i told you that
there are pairs of protein on er and
mitochondria that
help um form these molecular bridge and
let me remind you these are not
very static bridges these are very
dynamic structures which can form
and um disentangle again so it's
required on certain parts and
when it's not required it's
disentangled from each other so what we
wanted to do is express a couple of
these proteins
and if actin was facilitating this er
mitochondria
to promote the calcium transfer then by
expressing these
over expressing these proteins in the
knockout cells
would we get back the calcium arctic
phenols
so what we did was to express these two
proteins called tab b
and ptp ip51 now let me remind you that
if you over express both of these
together
the whole of the mitochondrial network
falls on the er because of the over
tethering of the air and mitochondria so
what we did
was express um either vampy or pgpip51
singularly in cells
and it's pretty well documented that if
you just express one of these partners
you have almost two to three-fold
increase in the er minor contact
um basically even before any treatment
so if our hypothesis was correct and
actin was facilitating this
this er miter contact then by expressing
these proteins in the ions to knock out
cells
we could artificially tether the er and
mitochondria
and now if we stimulated these cells
calcium should flow in the mitochondria
so here are the images for for whatever
i think
um the first lane is the wild-type cells
with the myocalcium here
and upon stimulation you have a rise in
the mitral calcium levels over here
in the inf to knockout cells that have
been transfected with
a control marker called x61 which lodges
itself on the er
you don't have much of these uh calcium
transfer happening
but if you over express ptpic which is
on mitochondria
shown here in green or vampy which is on
er shown here in green
both of these could rescue the
mitochondrial uptake phenotype in the
knockout cells
suggesting that and this is
a quantification so so these results
suggest that if you can
can rescue just the tethering function
of the ear and mitochondrium the calcium
flow is rescued even in the knockout
cell suggesting that actin filaments
were actively playing a role
in tethering the er and mitochondria to
promote these
of calcium transfers so let me
modify this working model um a little
bit
so we'll add some information over here
so this is what i showed you that
um the previous leaf that we have that
actin filament
helps assemble the grp1 that eats in the
mitochondrial division
now what i found out is
there is an additional step so these
actin filaments that form on the er
also facilitate first the er
mitochondria
and this er mitochondria helps in the
calcium transfer from er to mitochondria
now let me remind you again that this
mitochondria are excellent by
calcium buffer so it's simply that your
vr is
really using a lot of calcium and the
mitochondria
is mopping it up so the next question is
is this calcium transfer at all required
for mitochondrial derivation
to answer this question we try to limit
the calcium transfer in the mitochondria
and one way you can do that
is by inhibiting this complex called the
mitochondrial calcium uniporter
so calcium comes in the matrix of the
mitochondria
through this calcium uniporter that's on
the inner membrane and 90 percent of the
calcium comes in through this hemi water
and once you've blocked this uniform by
um
doing sir and immediate knockdown that
you can see over here um
what we saw is the mitochondrial calcium
updating these mcu knockdown cells
was severely reduced
but what was good for us to know that
these cells all um still had the actin
response so we have a scenario
where the calcium reflux from the er is
there
the actin response is there but the
mitochondria is not getting calcium
so in this scenario is the mitochondria
competent enough to divide
first we we did not do any stimulation
but we we just wanted to measure
decision events
in in the mcu knockdown cells and we saw
a very slight
uh but significant difference between
the number of fission agents in the mcu
knockdown cells
and interestingly if you add ionomycin
then the number of fission events that i
showed you in my one of my previous
slides goes up about threefold
standard control but in the mcu
knockdown cells
these mitochondria do not divide which
suggested that this action-mediated
calcium transfer into the mitochondria
is required for
the mitochondrial division
so now that we know that this calcium
transfer is required for mitochondrial
division
the apparent question was how does
calcium
influence mitochondrial deficiency
so after that we we did some close
imaging um
on on on the dragonfly and this is um
these are all done on the dragonfly
um scope so what we notice
is um if you observe mitochondria here
mitochondrial calcium and amido php
markers as this labels the mitochondrial
matrix
upon calcium in flux you will see that
there
are some bead on streams that form on
mitochondria or constrictions that form
a mitochondria some of which
um relax back and some of which result
in division
let me play the movie first so once i
play the movie
the calcium goes up and then you can see
these beat on streams
or constrictions that happen and there
are two tradition events happening right
over
here and one over here
um and some of these relax back so our
first hypothesis
was that um the drc1 was coming
around on the mitochondria and squeezing
parts of the mitochondria
and thereby you see these bulged out
regions which are regions which are
right across the lp1
so we repeated this experiment with a
drc1 knockdown itself
and contrary to what we thought there
was
actually a lot of these constrictions
that were forming after calcium in clubs
and these were not dividing
um we suggested that you need drp one
for mitochondrial division but
these constrictions were drp one
independent which also suggested that
these are not something coming from the
outer mitochondrial membrane but
might be generated from the inner
mitochondrial membrane
and we often term these as frustrated
constrictions is because you have a lot
of these constrictions but they don't
result in a full mitochondrial division
interestingly though when we imaged our
mcu knockdown cells which do not have
the calcium
uptake from these two images what you
can see the stark difference is we don't
have a lot of these constrictions
happening in these mitochondria
so these constrictions
were definitely independent of dip one
but also dependent on the calcium
flux so we suggested that calcium influx
for somehow influencing these
constrictions which
where are required for mitochondrial
division
so here's the quantification where in
the control cell um you have
a certain number of constrictions
happening after calcium influx
uh drp one you have a lot more to start
with and then
also there is a huge influx of these
constrictions
and most of these do not result in
mitochondrial position
um but in the entity you knock down
cells you don't have
a lot of constrictions to start with and
these numbers do not go
up when you add this calcium stimulation
so what do these constrictions really
mean for mitochondrial division
we followed these constrictions and the
mitochondrial division in in the
aeroscan microscope
and um here what we see is the
mitochondrial matrix is labeled in red
and the outer mitochondrial membrane is
labeled
in in green and
so upon calcium influx what you see is
the inner membrane dividing first
right over here so these are blown out
images
um which will try to see if there was
any tether that was there but we
couldn't find any tether of the matrix
but the outer membrane is still
connected over here
and then the outer membrane finally
divides in this region so what
what it meant was this calcium influx
which generated these constrictions
were actually dividing the inner
membrane first
which stayed divided and then the outer
membrane finally could snap
off under the influence of the drp1
so the the model that we have right now
over here is upon this calcium transfer
what you have is this imm constrictions
which are independent of the ip1
and these constrictions generate a
intermediate step where the imm divides
and c divided and this div 1 which
by the way also is helped by actin
filaments
can produce this constricting force and
divide the outer membrane so
what we found out that inf2 mediated
actin filaments
were promoting um dynamics and division
of both the inner membrane and the outer
membrane the inner membrane
dividing under the influence of this
calcium that was coming from er
and the outer membrane dividing under
the influence of drp1 and both of these
were regulated by the actin filaments
so with this i would end and i would
like to acknowledge a lot of people
um especially harry who has been a very
good mentor
and has given me the free run to to
explore
all these um uh induction was
worked a grad student was worked with me
on a different project which i couldn't
talk about um that
that involves the art complex and
mitochondrial dynamics
um i would also like to extend my thanks
for the imaging called zenik
and some of the past members especially
weaker who was
involved in with me in this project and
uh lastly i would like to thank andal
for giving me this opportunity to speak
and uh with that i would um pass on the
patent to meld it
for her talk thanks raj
hi everyone my name is meredith price
and i'm the product manager for amaris
here at andorr
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
amaris for mitochondrial research
but first i wanted to give a quick
introduction to the amaris family of
software
so we have four main softwares that i
want to tell you about today the first
is the the flagship the amara software
this is the one that allows you to
perform
that 3d and 4d visualization and
analysis of your microscopy images
and so those could be wide field
confocal light sheet
super resolution images were able to
open up a variety of different formats
and within the software you're able to
zoom in
rotate around create movies but also to
do that analysis where you're performing
segmentation and reporting results
then the next one is amara stitcher
this is a software that you'd use if you
have a very large specimen that you want
to
acquire images of at a high resolution
and the problem is
is that to acquire at such a high
resolution the whole specimen doesn't
fit within the field of view of your
microscope so you acquire
many different image tiles and then
after the fact you need to align those
and fuse them into one image so that
you're
either presenting or analyzing just one
image
as a whole and so amar's stitcher is
built for that job
and and so we have that it's nice and
easy to use
we also have two free softwares we have
a mars viewer which is a free image
viewer
it's able to open up a mars files that
you've
made within within the regular
mars software it's also able to open up
all the different file formats that
the mr software is able to open as well
and so you really can use this as a free
software
to view any of the 3d images that you
have out there
and we do open up tiffs if you're
interested in that
and nomar's viewer you can find that at
amaris.com
viewer a free download and then we also
have file converter and this is
um this is mostly useful for people that
are using stitcher
or amaris and want to be able to perform
the file conversions
on different computers to save
themselves some time
and so again this is a free software
that's nice and light and able to do
that for you
so we have those four those
those four members of the mars family
and for the rest of the talk today i'm
gonna
i'm going to talk just about um the main
omar software
and so what can a mars do for the cell
biologists
that are listening to this webinar right
now what amaris is able to do for you
is that it's offering at its core
the visualization of your images within
3d
so everyone listening right now knows
that the organelles within your cells
the cells themselves
and and the proteins they're actually 3d
objects
and so looking at them slice by slice is
not giving you that full view and so
of course we're doing that 3d
visualization for you
as well as being able to look at that
over time so that you can see
changes but in addition to just the
visualization we are able to perform
that
segmentation based on the labels that
you have within your image
to then report out morphological
measurements and so what i mean by that
are things like reporting volume or
um or surface area
as well as different shape measurements
to determine if something is elongated
in one axis or another
that sort of thing we're also able to
look at the dynamics
so if you're lucky enough to be doing
live imaging that was my background
you know that you there's a number of
different things that you might want to
do
as a as someone looking at a live sample
you might just want to see
how the position of an object changes
over time
you your mitochondria might be moving
around or they might be
changing shape and you want to see how
that changes over time
and that's something that a mars can do
as well
what we see um many times
with with cell biologists is that
they're looking to get
a readout of co-localization within
their images as well
so we do the traditional intensity-based
co-localization
you may have heard of pearson's
coefficients and that sort of thing
we're able to report those measurements
but we're also seeing many many people
looking
at object-based co-localization and
what that means is that first you would
go into a morris and you would identify
your objects just like you would
um to create these morphological
measurements
but then once you have them for your
let's say your two different organelles
or your mitochondria
that's labeled in two different ways you
have two different populations of some
sort
once you have those then you can see are
they interacting
in certain ways are they touching one
another how many objects are touching
one another
we can also help you understand the
spatial distribution
of your organelles or your proteins
within the cell
so for that it's not just understanding
where they are within
the image but you want to understand
where they are
in relation to a certain object and so
that could be the nucleus or you could
pick a specific reference point
we also allow you to understand how far
away they are
from the edge of the cell and so those
are some built-in
tools that we have with nmrs that can
help you get the exact kind of results
that you're looking for
to help you with your specific
experiments and research
so now i wanted to show you a couple of
different ways that
some of our customers have used amaris
in their research
we have an example here from jennifer
lippincott schwartz's lab
and sarah cohen was nice enough to give
us
the rights to show this image where
you're seeing different organelles and
their distribution within
just one cell and so what they did was
they used a tool
that's in a previous version of a mars
called distance transformations
to help them understand how far away
objects are from one another so how far
away
are in this case these are mitochondria
and we have other types of organelles in
the different colors here
how far away or how often are each of
these organelle types touching another
organelle type
and as i said in the past we had this
through
a tool called distance transformation
and now we have that built into amaris
with the newest version
9.5 and then over here on the right hand
side
instead of using our surface tool like
sarah did instead this lab was able
to segment out their their mitochondrial
label that they have you can see the
fluorescent image on the left-hand side
and they used the filament model and so
this model is
able to give you um measurements for the
length
of the mitochondria even if they are
curvy like a snake
that sort of thing and so you can see
that model here it's less of a blobby
model
and more of a a column or a rope
something like that to do that analysis
and characterization and so
in this example they were looking over
time and they could see how
the shape of the mitochondria changed
over time
and both of these are found within our
learning center
at omarus.com and you can look up these
names to find out more
about exactly what they did and then
find the original paper
as well so today i hope you've learned a
little bit about how a mars could help
you with your own research
if you are interested in learning more
just let us know we'll make sure to
reach out to you
you can also go on to our website to
find more as well
and now i think claudia is gonna get
started
and um so i'm gonna send it over to her
thanks
thank you meredith and thank you dr
chakravarti for your presentations and i
will wrap
up presenting the dragonfly multi-mode
system
and showing why it is an essential
system an outstanding system for imaging
intracellular dynamic events
so common challenges in the imaging
interstellar dynamic events
include avoid phototoxicity and
photobleaching
and while avoid phototoxicity and
photobleaching researchers
also need to acquire the images with
enough temporal
resolution to visualize the dynamic of
the event that they are
acquiring and studying such as either
being
a very fast dynamic event or
a very long time time-lapse experiment
also the accurate spatial resolution
is needed to capture all the information
of the biological process
and sometimes lifestyle super resolution
it is also required
the throughput of data to increase the
productivity researchers
will benefit on being able to image
multiple imaging fields
in a single experiment to have more data
to analyze and have their
experiments to being statistically
significant
allow the access of multiple imaging
modalities
will allow the researcher to tackle
different biological problems
or use different imaging technologies
to answer one biological question
for fluorescence illumination microscopy
we have
white field imaging where all the light
that goes through the sample is captured
by the detector
turf imaging where the light the sample
is imaged
in an angle and only a scene that
section
at the surface of the sample is captured
by the detector
and the confocal techniques point
scanner and confocal where a single
pinhole discards the auto focus light
and spinning disk multiple pinholes
will discard the autofocus light and in
the next slide i will compare
point scannings with spinning disk
dragonfly
so single point scanning confocal will
scan the image point by point by point
and this as you can imagine as you can
see it is a very long lasting process
whereas the dragonfly multi-point
confocal will deliver
the image in an instant
furthermore dragonfly benefits from
endor's
emc cds and nc and scmos cameras
technology
with up to 90 percent of comp quantum
efficiency
capturing all the photons nearly all the
photons
that come from your imaging whereas the
single point scanning confocals the
pmt's photomultiplier tubes have
up to at the most 45 percent of quantum
efficiency
dragonfly multi-point scanning confocal
is based on the dual micro length
spinning technology
it is a high contrast multi-modal
photoform
it is an instant confocal because it
delivers confocal image in an instant
but it is a multimodal platform because
besides
of being a cofocal it also delivers
laser white field imaging super
resolution techniques such as this storm
and surf stream and turf imaging
dragonfly comes with the borealis
illumination system
allowing a very flat uniform
unilamination
across the whole wavelength from the
visible
to the near infrared wavelengths
key specifications of the dragonfly
include up to 400 frames per second in
the confocal mode
a very large field of view and the very
broad
excitation wavelength and highly
uniformity
across the excitation wavelength with a
16-bit
dynamic range of capturing the image and
this is very important because you can
acquire
all the signals in an image from the
very dim
to the very high signals without having
imaging saturation
or losing any of the low signals
therefore it is not surprising that a
dragonfly
can be used for a very broad range of
applications
such as live and fixed cell imaging
membrane dynamics
cell and developmental biology cancer
research
organoid biology neuroscience and single
molecule
localization imaging
so i will now present real life examples
of
overcoming life imaging challenges with
the drug
this example researchers were able to do
a time lapse for 48 hours
using the fishy system acquiring images
with a double color simultaneously and
even 48 hours of
imaging the cell cycle dynamics cells
were still
dividing happily due to the
dragonfly spinning disk system
but if you want to acquire very fast
events such as
calcium imaging you can also use the
dragonfly acquiring images for example
at 53 frames per second and with the
dragonfly you can acquire
dynamic events up to 400 frames per
second
but sometimes researchers need super
resolution
and need super resolution in live cell
the problem is that
techniques that deliver super resolution
most of the times are not compatible
with life cell imaging
and why due to very complex sample
preparation
due to very long times required to
deliver an image
and very importantly due to the high
energy requirements
to deliver a super resolved image in
2016
professor ricardo hicks have developed
surf
which is an algorithm that delivers
super resolution
images that is compatible with live cell
imaging
furthermore ricardo have collaborated
with andor
professor ricardo has collaborated with
under and we have developed surfstream
which is an algorithm in in bevit
in our fusion software
dragonfly software and in our cameras
surfstream will yell an increase in
resolution
between two to six times more in the
final data
delivering super resolution images on
the fly
in the instant while you are acquiring
the low power requirements for
surfstream make it compatible
with live cell images and can deliver
images that break the diffraction limit
as fast as 10 frames per second no
specific sample is required specific
sample preparation
is required and super resolved images
can be
delivered deep inside cells or tissues
but the dragonfly can also deliver other
imaging modalities
such as turf for example for high
resolution
cell surface events as the ones that i'm
showing here
using the thaline and the dlc1
genes in green and red respectively
but if you want to have access to more
resolution
and doing single molecule localization
microscopy you can do that
with the dragonfly using this storm
increasing the density power
of the illumination and here you have an
example of resolving
neuronal spines with this storm
dragonfly can also deliver 3d the storm
data
using an astigmatic lens
but also dragonfly can be used for deep
imaging
due to custom pinhole spacing the
dragonfly
is ideal to image deep inside cells or
tissues
as in this example of this cleared
vessel's brain
where 2.4 millimeter deep were
imaged as you can see in this video
the borealis illumination system allows
very flat illumination across the whole
field of view delivering
very high contrast and very flat
illumination which is
which is ideal for stitching and
quantification
four as for an example if you want to
image this zebrafish and
want to image it all without noticing
the tiles
due to borealis illumination you can
have the image of the whole
fish but you can acquire this fish with
the 60 hex
or the 100x lens and see the details for
example that you are interested in study
in the eye you see the details in the
aisle but you also see the whole
phenotype
of the fish stitching the whole fits
together
without any noticing of the adjacent
tiles
fusion the dragonfly software
also allows real-time deconvolution so
you can increase the signal-to-noise
ratio of your image
and also the resolution of your image
and
deal seeing what is happening in real
time with
fusion clear gpu deconvolution the
dragonfly comes in two models the
dragonfly 500
a complete solution delivering all the
imaging modalities that i had just
mentioned
and the dragonfly 200 a more compact
solution that is offered
in the upright and inverted systems
so going back to the first slide due to
very gentle illumination the dragonfly
allows you to image
avoiding phototoxicity and
photobleaching
and also delivering the temporal
resolution that you need to acquire the
dynamic events
are if either very long time lapse
or very fast dynamic experiments
the dragonfly can deliver real-time
live cell super resolution and therefore
you can acquire
the spatial resolution with all the
information you need to capture
your biological processes due
to the stitching capability the allow
the ability to acquire
multiple tiles multiple fields it will
allow you to increase productivity
of your life cell experiments
the access of multiple imaging
modalities
either confocal whitefield
storm turf surfstream allow you to
tackle
the same biological problems in a
different angle
or multiple biological problems and
therefore delivering
all you need for your imaging biological
experiments and this is
all for now i'm very happy to take any
questions
thank you all
thank you dr florindo and dr chakravarti
for your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
dr florinda let's start with you can you
give me
a real life example that demonstrates
the productivity
of the dragonfly
uh so thank you for your question and i
imagine this comes in line with the
presentation of the spinning disk and
the productivity of using a spinning
disk
versus a point scanner so
if i think about it i remember
that in april we have posted
on twitter on our twitter account a
three color
image that had more than a 150
tile and i think more than
80 000 images and all of this
was acquired in under 30 minutes
and so i remember more or less these
members i think it's more than this
i'm not completely sure but
if it's 8 000 images more than 150 tiles
three color images it's it is very
strong
productivity of the dragonfly thank you
so much
and thank you and dr chakravarti let's
come over to you
does mitochondrial calcium uptake
regulate
drp1 oligomerization on mitochondria
that's that's a great great question in
fact i didn't have time to show the data
but
what we did show is um
the mcu knockdown which restricts the
calcium
entry into the mitochondria in that
scenario the drp1 oligomerization
on the mitochondria was absolutely fine
so which suggested that
it has uh independent pathways
and the mitochondrial calcium per se
does not determine the drp1 ability to
get onto the mitochondria
but definitely the cytosolic calcium
levels do influence and there is a
pathway for that
so thank you it's a good question
thank you and let's go ahead and have
you answer this question as well
does constriction and or imm division
require an active etc
that's a great question in fact we have
done this
so to to cut the long story short it
does influence so if you
um block the electron transport chain
using various inhibitors like the
complex one inhibitor or the complex
three inhibitor
um antimycin and bottom on uh we see a
significant decrease in the number of
constrictions
and as well as the number of divisions
so yeah you need a functional electron
transport chain
complex to be running to facilitate
those
uh constrictions that happen after
calcium
stimulation
thank you and dr florendo let's wrap
with this final question
is it possible to use photo manipulation
tools with the dragonfly
yes it is we at andor also supply photo
manipulation tools
that can use to be used with a dragonfly
or with other microscope systems
namely the micropoint and mosaic
micropoint is high power laser
for high power applications such as dna
damage
and mosaic is a device most suitable for
optogenetics
it is extremely fast and allows the
simultaneous illumination of multiple
regions
and if you want to know more about
this photo manipulation tool
go to under website or contact one of us
and thank you very much for your
questions
thank you dr florendo and also thank you
dr chakrabarti for your time today in
your informative presentation
do you either of you have any final
comments for our audience
uh i could say that i would like to
thank
dr shaka bharti and meredith for for
giving the talk and especially
dr shakabati to show us the importance
of his mitochondrial research and also
to show
us how does the dragonfly is useful
to do his research and i would like to
let you all know if you want to know
anything
more about the dragonfly over mary's
please contact us
at the andor website thank you all
and thank you dr florendo thank you
now before we go i would like to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
those questions we did not have time to
answer live today
and additionally those submitted during
the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided
at the time of registration i would like
to once again
thank dr raj chakravarti dr claudia
florindo
and meredith price for their time today
and for their important research
we'd also like to thank labruts and our
sponsor andor
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event you will now be
redirected to the registration page for
our next
and or webinar titled surf and turf
simultaneous spatiotemporal
super resolution and multi-parametric
fluorescence microscopy
presented by thorson wohlen professor of
biological sciences and chemistry
national university of singapore and dr
alan mullen
product specialist for microscopy
cameras at andor technology
this webinar will broadcast live july
16th at 8 am pacific time
11 a.m eastern time 5 pm central
european summer time
we hope to see you there
you